endlich mal die millionen gewinnen
deswegen spielen viele deutsche immer
wieder lotto
derzeit sind zwölf millionen euro im
jackpot und wenn der schule bei
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung aufpasst
kann seine chancen erhöhen und für alle
die hier noch nachhilfe benötigen
spreche ich jetzt mit professor doktor
christian hesse er ist leiter der
abteilung mathematische statistik an der
universität stuttgart und kann uns
erklären wie wir zumindest
wahrscheinlicher an die millionen kommen
ja welchen trick gibt es denn sechs
richtige im lotto zu bekommen ja hallo
frau platil ich grüße sie zunächst mal
also man kann sagen ein todsicheres
system gibt es natürlich nicht um sich
einen sechser zu garantieren wenn es das
gäbe dann würde ich jetzt nicht hier
sitzen und mit ihnen plaudern sondern
wäre wahrscheinlich bei der nächsten
lotto annahmestelle und würde
lottoschein ausfüllen aber es gibt
immerhin ein system um sich ein sechster
zu garantieren wenn man fünf richtige er
hat und man muss ein bisschen aufwand
betreiben
man muss 44 lotto felder ausfüllen und
zwar wählt man sich fünf zahlen die
trinkt man bei jedem dieser 44 lotte
felder ein
und dann fügt man jeweils eine der
übrigens herr noch hinzu also beim
ersten leute feld eine eins bei dem
zweiten motto führt eine zwei und so
weiter führt alle 44 zettel ausbilder
und dann wenn tatsächlich die fünf
zahlen die man gewählt hat kommen dann
hat man garantiert ein sechser dabei
aufgrund des systems und 43 5 und da die
wahrscheinlichkeit für fünf richtige 258
mal so groß ist wie die für einen lotto
sechser hat man damit seine chancen
immerhin um einiges vergrößert
gut das klingt nicht unbedingt einfach
welche zahlenkombinationen soll ich denn
vermeiden vermeiden sollte man einiges
zb kein datum tippen also weder
geburtstage der kinder hochzeitstage man
sollte muster vermeiden also zahlen die
irgendwelche muss da auf dem zettel wie
kreuz
jahrhundert dann keine mathematischen
professionen wie man das so sagt er war
kritik also zahlenfolgen 7 14 21 28 denn
all diese verfahrensweisen führen dazu
dass wahrscheinlich eine sehr große zahl
von anderen lotto spielern die auch
gewählt hat bei millionen tipps die die
jeweils abgegeben werden und das
wiederum bedeutet dass man sich im falle
eines gewinnes die ausschüttungssumme
mit ganz vielen anderen wir teilen
müssen und dann gewinnt man natürlich
entsprechend weniger
mit welchen zahlen kombinationen
gewinnen am wenigsten auch wenn man
sechs richtige hat
ist eindeutig der tipp der besteht aus
den zahn 123456 möchte dass ein kurioser
tipp das ist die am häufigsten der am
häufigsten gewählte tipp tatsächlich
woche für woche gibt es einige tausend
lotto spieler und spielerinnen die damit
ins rennen gehen
und wenn diese tatsächlich einmal kommen
sollten dann werden diese enttäuscht
sein nach vielleicht ein bisschen
vorfreude oder freude dass man gewonnen
hat kommt dann die ernüchterung wenn
sich später herausstellt dass man dafür
keinen sehr großen gewinn einheimsen
kann ja auch als passwort sind sehr
diese zahlenkombination nicht zu
empfehlen wie wir immer wieder hören
welche tipps haben sie denn um einen
höheren gewinn zu erzielen
man sollte einzigartig spiel also so
dass man wenn man gewinnt mit niemandem
oder jedenfalls ganz wenig menschen
urteilen muss also wenn man wenig
aufwand betreiben will kein system
spielen wird kann man mit dem zufall
gegen den zufall spielen also etwa in
folgender weise 49 zettel mit 49 zahlen
drauf in ein hut ein bisschen schütteln
dann sechs zahlen auswählen und schauen
ob die irgendwelche muster bilden auf
dem motto zetteln also mal kurz
ankreuzen dann ist es auch günstig wenn
deren summe mindestens 164 ist weil dann
vermeidet man tippt gleichheit mit etwa
80 prozent der menschen die mit
getippten datumsangaben also
hochzeitstagen kindergeburtstag ins
rennen geht also in nicht zu kleine
summe kein muster bilden und ansonsten
eine zufalls tippreihe wählen dann ist
man ganz gut aufgestellt
herr professor der hesse vielen
herzlichen dank für diese tipps spielen
sie denn selber auch lotte ich spiele
kein lotto weil ich nicht der der
spieler für glücksspiele bin ich ich mal
hier ich mag strategiespiele ganz gern
also mach jetzt in dem fall ezb